心には勝てないんです
決して物質は ですから
とにかくその話は関係ないんですけど
で またアビダルマに戻ります
で 心というものがとにかく何かを刺激
何かを対象を認識して自分が回転している
それ対象全部消えちゃったら自己回転する法則もあるんです
その寝たら深い眠りに入ったら我々にわかる認識がないんです
その時は自己回転というものが起こっているんです
ですから 自分を持ってるような気で自己回転する
それあんまり持ってるのに自己回転しているのはあんまり面白くないんだから
人は目が覚めちゃいます
あの ずっと寝ていることはできないんです
20年とか 40年とかね
まあそういうことだから
まあそんなめったなことでは死なないということはまあまず理解した方がいいんです
死んでも心は止まらないんだから
死んでしまってもこの生ではね
止まらない そのままもう回転は続けちゃう
そこでアビダルマの今日のポイントにくるんです
そこから そこで心はこう思っているんです
自分がこの頼っている眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報がなくなったら
これ大変だと 自分命な命を大変な危機になるんじゃない
命生きてる その意味は
目からものを見て 耳から音を聞いて
鼻から香りを嗅いで 舌から味を味わって
体から感触に触れて頭で考えている
その 6つの働き それは私たちの命なんです
いろんな哲学の世界では魂
霊魂とか何とか言うんだけど
仏教ではすごい具体的に
その認識の働きは そのものが命という言葉なんですね
他の教えで命 魂 霊魂 なんとか何とか言っているのは
この六根の働きなんです
そこは自分の命だから
大事に守りたいんですね
死にたくないんだから
だから我々は徹底的に眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報に頼っているんです
目から何か見えないとものすごく心配するんです
不安になるんです 耳から音が入らないとすごい不安になっちゃうんです
舌がいろんな美味しい味が食べないと
ものすごく精神的に不安になってストレス溜まっちゃうんです
いくら健康にいいと言ったっても
味もない 形も良くない
美味しくない食べ物を 1週間ぐらい食べてみてください
もうものすごく嫌になっちゃうんです
例えば栄養は全部揃っている
この錠剤みたいな ちょっとしたことで栄養全部取れますからね
タンパク質もカロリーも全部ビタミンもミネラルも薬みたいな形ででも取れますよ
じゃあ 2 日間頑張ってみてください
ご飯食べないで 栄養入ってる
この栄養食品と言わないね
その場合は このサプリメント
2 日間経っちゃうと この人誰か殺すかもしれません
ストレス溜まっちゃう
別に合理的に考えるとちゃんと栄養取ってるんだから
これ病院なんかではね
家でご飯食べられない場合は
この点滴ですか なんとかもうもう方法で栄養あげれるでしょ
それで患者さんが元気で食べなくてもものはすごいもんですねとか喜んでいればいいのに
悩んでるんでその代わりに
栄養はちゃんと病院で計算してきちんとあげてるんです
ですから 食べたよりは安心なんです
医学的には でも生命としてはとんでもない話なんです
いつカツ丼食べるかなとその患者さんが考えてるんです
うどん食べたいと そういうふうなものなんですね
だから 我々は目に目から情報入らないと心配
耳から音を入らないと心配
普通の人々は田舎なんかいたらもう1日2日でも飽きちゃうでしょ
もういられないんですね
いわゆる刺激がないんです
それですぐもう都会に逃げ
逃げるというか走ってくるんですね
それで理解していただきたいのは
私たちは目耳鼻口体には徹底的に依存している
なくなったら心配する
不安になる 自分が殺されてるように怖くなる
恐怖感が出てくる だから人を怖く恐怖感を作ってあげることはとても簡単なんです
音は聞こえないようにしてあげたら
ものは見えないようにしてあげてください
えらい怖くなるんです
なんで夜怖いんですか？何のこともないでしょうに
今皆様経験ないんですね
東京はとんでもないんだから
日本はもう 暗闇は知らないんですね
だからまあまあ 私たちの国のようなところでも
まあ夜で行ってみてください
もう街灯とかもうないんだから
夜は暗い みんなビビるでしょうと思いますよ
でもこちらより安心だと
安全だと思いますけど
子供でも夜暗闇怖いでしょう
なんでバカなこと経験もないのに
夜も夜は怖いとはね 聞いてみてください
何が怖いですかねとか
全然答えがないんですね
あれなんですかね 夜は怖いの
目から情報が入らないんだからなんです
ただそれだけ で 大人には夜はやっぱり怖くて
もう懐中電灯でも開けてください
まあそこで平気ですね
目から情報入るんだから
音を聞こえない時も同じことなんです
ものすごく怖くなるんです
汗が出るんです 体震えるんです
ですから 例えば音は全く入らない部屋に人を入れちゃったら
もう怖くなって震えちゃうんです
まあ人間はその時どうします？自分で叫ぶんです
だから暗闇と違うところはそこなんですね
音は全くない部屋に人を閉じ込めちゃったら全く入らない
完璧にこのサウンドプルーフ部屋に入れちゃったら
自分で叫んだり歌ったり
いろんなことするわけです
して音を入るようにしているんです
ですから 喉に麻酔でも打ってね
音は作れないようにしておけば
もう怖くて あの音が出なくなっちゃったら経験あります？結構怖くなるんです
そういう 例えばひどい風邪ひいたりとかね
で 声帯が動かない時もあります
私も一回だけ経験があったんだけどね
徹夜してずっとすごい雨に降られちゃって
もう風邪引いていたり
その上雨に濡れちゃって
また徹夜ずっと朝まで外にいなくちゃいけない羽目になって
で 朝は別に熱とか何もなかったんだけど
人と喋ろうと思ったら一言も出てこない
音が こっちはひどい病気なのに
向こうは全然気にしないといろんなこと言ったりする
そこじゃ喋れないし まあしょうがなく
まあ一日ぐらい我慢したところで
まあどんどんどんどん風邪が治ってくると
また声が戻ったんだけど
声が消えちゃったらものすごい精神的なショックになっちゃうんです
だからそこを仏教学的に見ると
何のこともないです このショックっていうのは
この自分が殺されてるんだというショックなんですね
命を侵せるんですね 命そのもの
で 眼耳鼻舌身から情報が入ることは命であって
自分の命なんですね 情報が入らないようになっちゃうと
この人が自分の命が失っていくんだと
ですから 死の恐怖感を味わっちゃうんです
そこでショックきちゃうんです
で そこら辺はヨーロッパの心理学ではないところなんです
ただ 人の精神的なショックですから
何とかして何とかして治そうとしているだけで
で 合理的に言えば 例えば人が目が見えなくなっちゃう
それで精神的にショック受けるんだと
だから見えなくたってあなた死ぬわけないでしょうと
それぐらいのことなんですね
見えなくなった だから何ですか
死ぬわけないでしょうと
それぐらいのこと ですから
目が見えなくなったんだから
あんた一生懸命今心配して混乱して
耳も聞こえないようにしてくださいと
その方が一番いいんじゃないですかと言ったら
腹が立ってもう落ち着くんです
それほど難しくないんですよ
生粋ですけど そのやり方はね
でもその概念はヨーロッパ心理学ではないんですね
仏教ではそれはもうあって
これ眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報は命そのものであると私たちが思っている
なぜならば生きているということは心の回転であります
心を回転するためには
眼耳鼻舌身から刺激を与えてあげなくちゃいけない
そこで眼耳鼻舌身から刺激を与えないということは
心の回転に邪魔をすることになっちゃう
心の回転を邪魔するっていうことは
その人の命を侵されていることになっちゃうんです
そこでものすごく怖くなるんです
精神的なショックで 治療方法として言えるのは
それぐらいのこと知りませんよと
心の回転は全然止まりませんと
どう頑張っても ということなんです
でも理解しますよと言っている
そこで我々が眼耳鼻舌身の情報にとことん頼っていて
絶対離れませんと 徹底的に執着している
囚われているんです だから次元の中に閉じ込められているんです
だから全然 いくら頑張っても超越した智慧が生まれないんです
なぜならば 目から入る物質的な情報
それで十分だと 耳から入る音
それで結構だと 音だけ探していく
目に入る色だけ探している
舌に入る味だけ探している
探し求めている 何を探し求めていますかというと
色声香味触 色声香味触という五つ探し求めているんです
それで我々の次元は徹底的に決まっているんです
超能力を得ようと思ったっても得られない
無駄な努力 この超能力を得ていろいろ工夫やってますけどね
世間の人間が 無駄な努力なんで骨折りだけなんです
だからこの禅定 あるいは超越した智慧が生まれない
それを妨げている原因
1番目は何ですか？これなんです
眼耳鼻舌身に徹底的に頼っていること
あるいは色声香味触から離れたくない気持ち
それはパーリ専門用語でカーマッチャンガと呼ぶんです
[拍手]カーマ・チャンダ
で 日本語の言葉何でしたっけ？え？欲動？欲望
カーマ・チャンダという
日本語で欲望という欲は欲の欲と愛の愛なんですけど
文字は入れてますけど
ちょっと意味は通じないんですね
それでは カーマというのは
この言葉を分析して考えてください
カーマというのは色声香味触という５つなんです
カーマ 分析してみると
こちらにあるのは ここは一応パーリ語の言葉だけ書きます
ルーパ サッダ ルーパサッダガンダラサポッダッブという
日本語の こう書いてある字です
このルーパサッダガンダラサポッダッブ
色声香味触 この５つにカーマというんです
そこで感じ チャンダ チャンダっていうのは恋しがるという
希望しているという意味なんですね
囚われている 希望している
恋しがっている 欲みたいなものなんです
欲というのはその意味かな
欲しいと思っていることなんで
欲みたいなもので だから色声香味触に対して欲があるんです
三次元的な命を持ってる生命はもう残念ながらこれこの辺に持ってるんです
カーマ・チャンダという
欲望という辺に持ってるんです
ですから超次元の心が生まれません
生まれる心は全部この目から入る情報
耳から入る情報 それだけじゃなくて
例えば我々知っている科学的な現代的な知識では
眼耳鼻舌身から入らない情報は否定までする
それは非科学的で嘘やと
例えば仏教で言ってる輪廻転生の話なんか
そんなものは嘘だと 科学的じゃないんだと
そこまで言うんです それは気持ちはわかるんです
一つは眼耳鼻舌身の情報じゃないんですね
それは 人が知ってるのは眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報だけなんですね
そこまで私もやっぱり向こう側が言ってることはわかりますよ
でも私は文句言いたいのは
それだったらなんで神様人を創ったということを信じているんですかと
いい加減あれも捨てろと
何も証拠ないんだから
そこを信じてるんですね
だからまあバカもいいところだと
別に輪廻転生なんかはもう非科学的でいいと
それ別に腹立てる必要ないんですよ
非科学的だから それはそうですよと
でも神様があんた人間を創ったと思ってるでしょと
それはそう思ってるんだから
ですから 科学的になれば徹底的に科学的になってほしいんです
まあそこはとにかく私たちは目から情報が入る
入らないと怖くなる 耳から情報が入らないと怖くなる
殺されてるような感じがする
世の中の恐怖感の中で一番怖い恐怖感は死の恐怖なんですね
ですから そのハンディはもうなかなか乗り越えられないんです
もし私たちの心がこんな目から耳から鼻から口から体から情報入らなくなっても
もう大丈夫だと そんなの面倒くさいだけだと
ほんの微かな情報しか入らないではないかと
宇宙がもう自分がものすごい大きな入れ物の中に入っちゃって
こんな小さな穴五つ作って
その小さな穴五つから入る微かな光だけ見て
見て 私は宇宙は全部知ってるんだとかね
威張ってることだからね
自分入ってるこの何て言いますか
入れ物を破ればいいのに
そうするとこの五つの穴がなくても全部見えるはずなんですね
それは破れないんですね
ですから このアビダンマで言ってるこの色界の第一禅定も
このこの障害あると生まれません
で これ第一禅定を作るためには瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですね
瞑想すると なんで瞑想うまくいかないかというと
本当は好きでやってるわけじゃないんです
瞑想に興ってる人でも好きでやってるわけじゃないんです
もう何かそれなりの訳があってやってるだけで好きじゃないんですね
例えばもう遊ぶことは面白いなってなったら遊ぶことやりますけど
いろいろあって 人間っていうのはね
まあ社会的な行動をやめたりしますからね
そういう何かのわけがあって
社会的な行動もいいですよと宗教的な世界に入りますよと思って瞑想したりする
でも本当の心の状態はやりたくないんですね
だから心はもうとことん修行する人の心も心の中で眼耳鼻舌身から情報が入ってる世界はいいなと思ってるんです
楽でいいな その気持ちある限りは
心は三毒の中なんです
これは十年瞑想とかね
十五年瞑想してるとか
そんな勝手に威張ったってもね
何の意味もないんです
そういうふうに威張りたくはなるんですね
私は十年やってるんですよと
だからって何の意味もないんですよ
心の中で深いところで
やっぱり楽しく もう普通の普通の人々
若者みたいに もう遊んで楽しく楽に生活できればいいっていう気持ちはどこかにある
それはカーマ・チャンダというわけです
これはいつか本気になって
世の中の欲の世界がもう本当に嫌になったならば
いわゆる智慧で 本当にそれは意味がないんだと
その世界は狭いんだと
この世俗的な世界がシャバ世界がものすごい狭くて
もう嫌な世界だなと納得いったところで
カーマ・チャンダはいくらか消える
いわゆる瞑想の世界に自分のチャンダですか
欲ですか 瞑想の世界に入る
いわゆるこういうこと
今みたいに強引に瞑想させなきゃ瞑想しない状態にいますけど
そうじゃなくて瞑想をやめなさいと言ったら怒られると
瞑想できないようにいろいろ工夫すると隠れてでもやるというぐらいに心が変えない限りは
この超次元のレベルには出てこないんです
例えば人に瞑想できないようにいろんな仕事を頼む
お使いを頼む もう買い物してくださいとか
もういろいろあっち行かせたりこっち行かせたり
もうそれで夜もいろんなことをやらされたりすると
そうすると体が疲れるわ
もういろんな商売やったりすると頭が混乱するわ
瞑想できない それでも
隠れてでもいろいろ工夫してでもやっちゃうぐらい
この瞑想の方にもう気が行ってるならば
もうカーマ・チャンダがない
今の状態では無理なんです
強引にやらせなきゃやらない
それはこの清浄の心が生まれないハンディの一番カーマ・チャンダ
まあそれ理解すればね
まあこの 4つはまあただ言葉だけでいいと思いますけど
2番目のハンディはビャーパーダというんです
ビャーパーダ これは椅子変わるでしょうね
[笑い]はい ここら辺に何か障害物を置いておけば
私はここに行けなくなっちゃいますけどね
椅子でも何かこっちに置いておけばね
あ こちら椅子があります
そうやって障害物を置いておけば
はい それではね ビャーパーダっていうのは分かりやすい
瞋恚 瞋恚と怒りですね
瞋恚の漢字はまあ うん
えっ Bです うん あーどっちでもいいです
あ こちらは B でも B でもどっちでもいいんです
それは日本語と不思議に同じ
サンスクリット語とパーリ語で B とバーの発音がもうほとんどダブっちゃう
同じなんです ですから
B の代わりに B 書いたっても
ビャーパーダと言ったっても同じ意味で
でもちょっとした差がありまして
つなげて言うとビャーパーダ
独立させちゃうとビャーパーダ
カーマ・チャンダ ビャーパーダなんですが
カーマ・チャンダ カンマして独立させ
さちゃうと その二というならばヴィーラーパーナです
そういうそれぐらいの差なんです
僕らはこのシンハラ語という僕らの言葉はシンハラ語だから
そのそれはパーリ語とサンスクリット語とものすごい直接関係ある言葉なんですね
ですから あの僕らはこの発音は厳密なんですね B
で使うときも D で使うときも
きちんと区別する インドでは区別はしない
また 他の国々でもあのあまり区別はしない
えーと 瞋恚 瞋恚っていうのは怒りであって
なんでこれで障害になりますかというと
それもこの三次元の問題なんですね
カーマチャンドといえば
眼耳鼻舌身からこの色声香味触の刺激を受けたいんですね
その方がいいやと ヴィーラーパーナっていうのは
その入る情報に逆らっちゃうんですね
だから怒るんですね で
怒る場合は 例えば目から何か
目で何か見ている それで人が口も開けて
よだれも垂らしながら綺麗なものをよく見ていると
それはカーマチャンドではないかと
なぜなら見たい 見たいんだから
美しいものを見ているんだから
そこである人がちょっと威張って
私はそんなこの欲の世界はないんだ
なんでこんなことを見なくちゃいけないんですかと怒ると
その人 欲がないと思いますか？あるんです
なぜならば 怒るためにもその見る絵はなければ怒りませんから
結局離れてるわけじゃないんです
対象に眼耳鼻舌身の色声香味触という対象に怒る人は
その対象について怒ってるんだから
この色声香味触から離れてないんです
ただ損してるだけ まあせっかく楽しめるのに
ある人がちょっと威張っても
それに怒ってるだけなんです
ですから この心の中で怒りある限りは
我々は三次元を乗り越えてないんです
何に怒るかというと 目から入る情報に怒るんだから
耳から入る情報に怒るんだから
ですから 第二番目の障害は怒り
瞋恚 次は何でしたっけ？懇親睡眠
次は懇親睡眠 パーリ語でティーナミッタというんです
二つの言葉なんですけど
一つの言葉として書くんです
ティーナミッタ これ懇親睡眠と日本語の言葉で言うんです
ティーナっていうのはもうこういう何て言いますか
なんかこの 膨らむなんか心が精神が縮むんですね
大きく膨らんで 自分の知識認識がね
明るくなるんじゃなくて
なんか自分の中身が縮んでしまっちゃうんですね
小さくなっちゃうんですね
隠れたくなっちゃうんですね
心が 明るい いわゆる堂々と明るく活発的になるんじゃなくて
弱く暗く控えて縮む 心が
それだったらどうやって超越
超越自然的 超越した知識が生まれるんだ
生まれるわけないでしょうに
いわゆる心の回転エネルギーなんですね
回転するエネルギーが少なくなっちゃうというかね
回転はするんだけど エネルギーとしてエネルギーはない
縮んじゃう ミッタっていうのはもう鈍い
鈍いということ ですから眠い
眠く眠たい状態なんですね
だるくて眠くなっている
で あの 私 だいたいだるくて眠くなっちゃうと
どうしてもね 頭っていうのは暗いでしょ
その時は 何か考えたくないし
何か活動したくないし
どこか隠れて寝たいだけなんですね
で 不思議なこと 私たちはもういつでも隠れたがるでしょ
これ人間いくら文化的な
大変あなた文明作ったとかね
威張ってますけど あんなもん嘘ですよ
本当に我々正直に私の心を見てください
本当の心 隠れたがってるんじゃないんですか？堂々と前に行くんじゃなくて
できればもう下がっていたいんですね
その方が落ち着くというかね
心っていうのは どこかで隠れたがっちゃう
その性質は心に自然にあるものなんです
動物なんか見たらものすごいわかりやすいんですね
動物はいつでも隠れる
隠れる 隠れる 隠れる 堂々と出てくるということはないんです
蚊ぐらいは堂々と人間の前に出てくるんだけど
あれは餌取るためだけなんですね
餌を食べたらすぐ隠れるんです
外へは出ないんです 人間も同じなんです
もういくらこんな文明作ったとかね
人類が素晴らしい文明を作ったとか威張ったって
結局動物そのものなんです
心はもう隠れる状態でいるんです
だから人の前に出ると不安
社会の前に出ると不安
よっぽどの心が病気でない限りは
政治家とかそういう社会リーダーシップは取らないんですね
そういう人々はまたすごい精神的な落ち着きないとかね
まあいろいろあるんです
で 隠れた方が落ち着くと
そういう社会のリーダーになっている人々でも
結局は隠れて生活してるんです
偉い人になったところで
一番権力取ったところで何をするんですかというと
自分の隠れ家を作るんです
一般の人とは口をきかない
会わない ああだこうだとかね
それで一番 例えば一番偉い人々の事務所とか見たら
誰も入らない事務所で
外の音も入らない事務所で
そこで世界を支配しているんだから
もうよく隠れたところで落ち着くんです
そこから偉そうな命令するんですよ
人の前で何も言えないんです
ですから このそういう世界を支配しているリーダーであろうとも
心が隠れているんです
外へ出たくない そのエネルギーがある限りは
もう超越した智慧が生まれないんです
瞑想は隠れてするもんなんですけど
それ邪魔が入るんだからね
だから精神的にはもう
自分の左側 右側 大戦争があっても何のことなく堂々といられるぐらいのもう隠れ場所
やはり何と言いますか
徹底的にこの不意という恐怖がない状態
心に作らなくちゃいけないんです
それにつなげて この睡眠
眠気 それもあるんですね
人間に聞けばね 一番やりたいものは何ですか？というと
正直に言えば一番やりやすい
で やりたいのは眠ることなんです
もう他の散歩が好きですよとかね
言う人はいますよ と言ってもね
これは本気かなと 一番やりたいのは眠ることでしょうね
寝たいと 結局基本的な心の状態というのは隠れたい
寝たい そんななんで寝たがるかというと
この寝たら眼耳鼻舌身から情報を探し求めて苦労しなくても済むんです
生きるために いわゆる命を守るために
我々は必死になって仕事をしているんですね
眼耳鼻舌身から情報を探しながら
寝たら心が軸回転するんだからね
苦労しないで済むんです
だから休むんですね ある程度で
だから当たり前でね もう寝たいんですね
その寝たいという気持ちがある限りはね
もう禅定なんかは生まれません
それも一つの巨大なハンディなんです
そのハンディだから それは生まれつきついているものなんです
ある特別な人にあるわけじゃないんです
生まれつき誰にでもあるんです
そこで今日の勉強で僕は理解してほしいのは
私は悪口ってみんなに批判しているというふうに腹が立つんじゃなくて
こういうものは生命の基本的な状態だと正直に認めることなんです
正直に自分の心に聞くと
ああ やっぱり自分もそんなもんだよと
五欲があるんだと カーマ・チャンダがあるんだと
瞋恚 怒りがあるんだと
それから昏沈睡眠があるんだと
隠れたい で 三番目の障害は
本当はこれちょっとこの話は飛んでるんで
この今日は出てくる話じゃないんで
これは後でこの深層の説明出てくるものですけどね
まあ瞑想実践してるんだから
これは今のうちも理解した方がいいんです
ウッダッチ 二つあるんです
ウッダッチというものとクックッチ
ウッダッチはなんか漢字で情考と書くんです
なんか変な漢字だそうですけど
クックッチは後悔 ウッダッチ
クックッチという二つのものがございます
まあだからこの五蓋というんだけど
結局こっちも二つあります
こちらも二つありましてね
七つぐらいあるんだけども
ウッダッチは情考と書いて何か訳の分からない意味なんですね
これはどういうことかというと
心っていうのは隠れたいでしょう
隠れている 隠れたがる心は外へ出たらものすごく不安になっちゃうんですよ
どうすればいいか分からなくなっちゃうんですね
で 皆様にいきなり人の前に立って喋ってくださいと頼んじゃったらどうなるんですか？いきなり
じゃああなたどうぞお願いしますと
例えば結婚式があるんだと
結婚式で誰が喋るかというと
前もって決まってますけど
自分も親戚の結婚式だから行ったと
行ったところで何のことなく
結婚式場で式をやってる時
いきなりもうこの親戚の代わりに御挨拶
何々様お願いしますと言われたらもう死ぬかもしれません
驚愕で これ二 三週間前で言ってくれなきゃ
準備するためには 別にやりたくないわけじゃないんです
もうやっと自分にも立場があるところだから
でもそういういきなり言われたらできないでしょ
あの状態は情考状態なんです
僕ら出家とは違うんです
いきなり頼んできても何のことなくできます
喋りますけど それより早く話をやめてください
頼んだわ いいんです 向こうはそれ知っていて
一応いろんな式とかありますからね
いろいろ話を頼むんですよ
挨拶とかね 頼む同時に三分ぐらいでお願いしますと